I want to get into ukulele Cal you
mentioned it and then you also talked
about banjo kazooie into in the office
and you agree with me that Kazooie is
the inferior one of the two don't talk
anyway before we get into that argument
which I'm gonna win what does this
ukulele the main question I want to know
is obviously it's people that used to
work on banjo kazooie into e when it was
rare and they were working on those
three platformers kind of a 964 days but
now platonic has formed its people that
work there and they're working on
ukulele which is very much like an
obvious spiritual successor to banjo
kazooie but how much does that translate
into the gameplay from what you've seen
so far yes so from what I've played I
wouldn't say it's really reference heavy
I was surprised I thought there'd be
more references like direct references
to banjo games but it's more in spirit
and grant kirkhope who did composing for
the original return to do sound design
and composing for this one so that is
very much the same and the menus are all
the same and so it's it's very much
banjo in style rather than an actual
content if that makes sense but there's
also like at the beginning can do a quiz
game so at the end of banjo kazooie
there's like a quiz final quiz thing
Grundy's furnace fun cuz I know that
whole game um that about that ending is
one of the reasons I don't like that
game as much as tui I'm big nerd I love
taking quizzes but this is win a game
huh what it was like yeah the SATs were
those a game to you I got a 2200 without
studying was 2200 that is not possible
1600 was the max in relation you're not
that much older than me Mike yeah the
max for me was 1600 I promise you know
you're not that much older than me my
prime okay all right I'll get you in
that case I got a really bad score I
should not have gone to college or be
here right now um anyway but so there's
a like I said it's mostly in how it's
done rather than what the content is so
far but yeah is a little contrary to
what I was expecting I was expecting
more Easter eggs and I have only seen
that the UI looked just banjo kazooie
exactly the same yes sound effects are
the same uh yuka sort of
sounds like sexy grunty when you die and
banjo kazooie you know she's like yeah
yep sounds like that mmhmm yeah it's
very similar well there ya when you're
doing the actual when the dialog pops up
it's it's those talking heads yes to
those like lines of dialogue scrolling
you know like comic sans looking don
yeah what about the structure of the
game so far you said there's like this
hub world but from what I I played a
preview last year it was still pretty
early and build but seemed like it was
more geared aren't you unlock rather
than these areas existing and their item
gated by like jiggies or ever it as in
this game aren't you getting pages that
build on the world itself they I forgot
how they explained it to me but do you
have any more insane to that yeah so
it's less linear not that banjo kazooie
is strictly linear but basically you're
finding pages instead of jiggy's it's a
very similar structure but you can
unlock like an expanded version of the
world so like you'll you'll be exploring
a world and that will be a point where
you can't go any farther but you can see
like oh I'm supposed to go over there
but there's no wait for me to get over
there you have to spend the pate like
pay geez I think it's what they're
called yeah to to expand it and like
open up a new a new area and then but
you can also choose not to do that and
just go on to the next world so you can
do it in any order you want and I would
like to point out that this snake's name
is trouser I don't get it yeah um how's
the camera because I played the toolbox
I think whatever they were in a camera
was like not good and it was just like
this is the camera needs to be good for
this cameras janky so yeah which worries
me because 3d platformers are pretty
much you need me or broken by their
camera i was playing yesterday and i was
capturing and I was like whoever he's
gonna edit this footage is gonna think
I'm super bad at this game cuz the
camera was just kind of flying all over
the place mm-hmm um and some point some
points and there was also a weird thing
where like one of this is a tribal stack
tropics I think it's called and 0 r if
that's called endless abyss that might
have been me playing on enough um but
there's like an area where the camera is
just fixed for no reason and so when you
come out of it like the camera the
camera like flew around on those
what's going on also you have to spray
pollen on these flowers yeah here's
another very banjo thing the
transformations yeah that uh Mambo used
to do yeah had that sounds like it feel
mechanically know from your initial
impressions um I mean it's very similar
it's all about collectibles um I think
my biggest I wouldn't say concern but
the the thing I'm hung up on is would I
enjoy it if I wasn't such a big banjo
person just because it's like a
childhood game of mine and the other
thing is like I'm playing the same sort
of like oh man I kind of just want to
play banjo and that's worrying me a
little bit of course I'm going to keep
playing and I'm very early on in ukulele
but those are two big questions and then
the other question is like if you didn't
play banjo-kazooie like what does this
offer you sure yeah it's kind of like
playing Mass Effect Andromeda makes me
want to play mass effect two mm-hmm and
I don't know that that should be the
case but I don't know that's kind of
like you know I guess up to each person
to judge but overall so I think you
played more of this game than you can
talk about right now cuz your review
will be a pool when the embargo is April
fourth so it's a while out okay cool so
you have a lot of time to play that
final thoughts based on the preview
going into like the next couple weeks
for say I'm a person who really likes
banjo kazooie and touhy and I am
wondering whether this game is worth my
time so far viously you can't you don't
have the full review but is it promising
so far overall yeah I'd say so I think
it does enough to try to break away from
the formula that might be a little dated
I mean I think they took a lot of steps
to make it like a little less linear and
give you more options and try to make it
modernized but with that same humor and
flavor so that part is promising to me
and I think definitely if you really
enjoy banjo it's probably worth taking a
look at cool you're playing on what xbox
one yeah cool awesome so uh anybody if
you want to see more about ukulele we
have a few interviews with platonic debs
from pretty much throughout the past
year or so we did like kind of do
something on whether it might spark
another slew of 3d platform games but if
you're
in those if you're in reading those you
can go check those out at gamespot.com
and like Callie said her review will be
up on April fourth on gamespot com
[Music]